il est super boite française qui vous
propose de venir partager vos photos
directement avec là où les personnes
âgées de votre famille alors je vous
explique par exemple vous avez une
grand-mère une arrière-grand-mère 90 95
ans voire plus il affinités et vous
voulez lui envoyer vos dernières photos
les partager et bien il existe une
solution c'est familier le truc est très
cool pourquoi parce que vous vous avez
une application d'ailleurs pour voir
plusieurs membres de votre famille qui
ont cette application vous créez un
groupe de famille et chacun va envoyer
ses photos qui s'afficheront sur le
cadre un discours directement chez votre
grand-mère ça apporte plusieurs
bénéfices déjà aide de pouvoir voir ce
qui se passe et garder le lien avec sa
famille et puis vous vous savez que tout
va bien parce que elle va pouvoir venir
liker la photo maintenant un petit cœur
directement dessus en plus il y a une
légende elle a les infos elle sait ce
qui s'est passé ici et ça et au-delà de
ça on peut faire un autre truc qui est
très cool et bien c'est envoyé un petit
message comme un texto qui va s'afficher
en grand ça permet de garder le lien
dans les familles sur sa vachement bien
innovation française et family
d'ailleurs dites-moi vous ça pourrait
vous intéresser de venir partager vos
photos directement avec une ou plusieurs
personnes âgées de votre famille marquer
le moi dans les commentaires